welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down all of the leaked
images for the upcoming film of the
Batman the photos which dropped earlier
this week confirmed some big fan
theories give us our first look at
Robert Pattinson and the time setting
for the movie throughout this video
we're going to be discussing everything
that you need to know about them and
giving our thoughts about how they leave
the door open to tie into the larger DC
EU obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined about the
movie then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into a
breakdown of all of the leaked Batman
images okay so the first photos that
leaked online actually dropped over the
Christmas and New Year holidays and they
give us a lot of information about the
general aesthetic of the film the images
that were posted on 30th of December
showcase a cathedral set being built as
well as a number of blimps floating
around it now this is important for a
number of reasons as firstly the
cathedral itself indicates that there
will be a big funeral scene in the film
no no points for guessing who that is we
do know that this film will sort of be a
reinvention of the Caped Crusader that
differs slightly from the recent
betrayal by Ben Affleck in Batman V
Superman and Justice League therefore it
does make sense to showcase his origin
story in some way though we all know the
Batman origin story as it's been done to
death
a bit like the Wayne's we've never
actually seen the characters funerals on
screen now this is something that I
haven't really seen people talking about
but it leaves a wealth of possibilities
open for character appearances that
introduce the big players in the movie
you have to understand that the death of
the Wayne's would have brought many
people together for this occasion and
thus it is possible that some of the big
names from the underworld could be in
attendance this could include a number
of bigger notable criminals such as
carmine Falcone who's been cast as John
Turturro
Falcone is a big big player in the
graphic novel along Halloween which this
movie is reportedly based upon so I
believe that this event will showcase
his ties with the Wayne's which we
discover in the book and also perhaps
introduces henchmen potentially the
penguin and many more the funeral will
provide an amazing place to set up the
big
of the city and I think that it's an
inspired choice to finally show this on
screen outside of the set we can also
see that it's surrounded by blimps those
shoutouts to the nineties kids that
remember blimps in case you don't they
were a huge aesthetic to the Gotham
skyline in the Batman animated series
from the 90s they added an almost
timeless feel to the work at the time
and it's clear that Matt Reeves is aping
them in some ways in addition to this
the set shows that it's been painted
black throughout perhaps teasing that
this could be a nighttime setting or
even a way to darken the environment the
anime is for the animated series
themselves used to draw on black paper
rather than white as this darkened the
colors and this could perhaps be a way
to mirror that stylistically or or could
just made a block out light from the
outside I don't know anyway I have seen
some people complain that the blimps
look a bit low-budget but often in movie
productions placeholders are put on to
set so the actors have something to
bounce off of they also allow visual
effects artists to understand
positioning and lighting so it is
possible that they could be polished up
once the film is wrapped and it's moved
on to the next stage of production the
photos that followed after were taken by
Twitter user 100 Jordan Lee and they
actually confirm a lot of things about
the film including its time setting and
a possible crime scene initially they do
seem rather blase just showing news vans
and police cars but due to some tiny
tiny details they actually confirm a lot
of things about the movie firstly the
news vehicles have HD written on the
side of them so all of the theories that
the movies will be set in the 90s are
now out the window
however news stations haven't really
bragged about filming and HD for at
least 10 years now so this confirms that
the movie will be set in the early to
mid 2000s the fact that the Gotham
Police Department are also riding around
in old Crown Victorias shows the
difference between the funding for
police services and the media clearly
Gotham PD isn't really getting the money
that they should be and this could also
explain why crime and corruption is so
high in order to require a Batman the
city needs to have a reason for his
existence and this does hint that the
police simply aren't equipped to deal
with the darker side of the city
there is someone who looks like they
could be the commissioner so this might
cement that Gordon is still a captain
all low ranking officer that similar to
the Dark Knight must work his way up
Jeffrey Wright has himself confirmed
that he will be in the movie so it does
look like he will be taking on the role
of Gordon as we reported last year
there's also a nice little Easter Egg to
Gotham action news which was actually a
station in the 1999 Tim Burton film
Batman so it's nice that Reeves is once
more paying homage to the visions that
came before
not long after these photos were posted
Twitter user Wade grabbed drop some
images that they'd taken from outside
their office that shows what appears to
be the penguin the penguin is of course
known for his signature collection of
weaponized umbrellas so this definitely
fits the character though though it
could just be Rihanna of abbess Aria
thought it was terrible
anyway the internet correctly guessed
that this was Colin Farrell and director
Matt Reeves confirmed this on Twitter
this morning by posting a gif of the
actor with the caption wait is that you
Oz and a bat symbol after it yeah it's
it's a hundred percent confirming it
looks wise it seems like the design team
are mirroring the design of emperor
penguin from the comic books and know
this was an Oswald Cobblepot it looks
like they've made some creative leaps
the penguin has never looked like this
on screen before but personally I'm
really liking it this comes off the back
of talks with Jonah Hill coming to an
end after he wanted 10 million dollars
for the role this is double what Robert
Pattinson wanted and I'm glad they kind
of filled the characters shoes with
someone else as I think Farrell will
deliver a lot better than he'll ever
could I did see a couple of people
saying that Batman villains getting paid
more than Batman himself is crazy but
yeah do your research
the villains on the whole always tend to
get paid more than the actor playing
Batman does but yeah Jonah Hill he isn't
of the same caliber as Jack Nicholson
Jim Carrey and Arnie in the 90s anyway
just just my opinion personally but I do
think that Ferrell is far more sinister
than Hillis the photos that followed
this then showed our first look at
Robert Pattinson as Bruce Wayne heavily
masked and hidden he was sat on a bike
observing what could potentially be this
crime scene that's brought the police
news vans and
penguin together it was also a helmeted
photo posted that if you notice the
different pants shows that this is a
stuntman so we could get some moments
where Bruce speeds away on his bike
either way he's observing the scene very
closely and the costume actually has a
lot of similarities to the Batman zero
yeah graphic novel in which the
character appeared on top of a bike
backpack and all not to say that they're
taking directly from this but I do think
that there are some similarities that
will probably be more apparent when we
see how framing is shot from the same
sort of angles as the panel bringing all
of these images together you actually
have a lot of added subtext to the film
his theories floating about that the
penguin will be the mayor of Gotham City
as he was in Batman earth 1 and it makes
sense for him to be at this location of
what is clearly a big crime scene
whether he causes they're all like Bruce
he's just observing it we don't really
know yet
but there's a lot going on here it also
shows that crime is high in the city and
that Bruce's know is this and has begun
studying the ins and outs of Gotham's
underbelly so yeah lots of interesting
interesting things in these photos now
before we get into the fan theories I
just want to shut down a photo that was
posted recently by we got discovered
that claim to be showing the design of
the bat suit this was actually revealed
to be an fx prop so yeah just in case
you think we've seen the first bat suit
image we haven't but I can't imagine it
coming out in the next couple of weeks
as I'm sure DC and just the creative
team in general will want our first look
to be a good image rather than one taken
by someone on a street corner now on to
the fan theories so weighing up the time
setting I actually think that this is
being set up to not only tie-in to the
recent Joker film but it's also been
made as a way to leave the door open
should DC wish to tie it into their
extended universe we're gonna be
spoiling the ending of Joker so if you
haven't had a chance to see the movie
yet then this is your time to turn off
if you still here thanks for sticking
around and hopefully this theory puts a
smile on your face
okay so firstly Joker was set in the mid
80s and the film culminates in the death
of the Wayne's in Crime Alley Bruce
Wayne is roughly about 10 years old
Ernest so by the time he ages up for the
2000s
also be roughly the same age that
Pattinson is in the film
Thomas Wayne was running for mayor in
that movie so with him no longer being
in place that could leave the door open
for penguin to step in and star ruling
the city now it has been widely
published that Joker was a standalone
movie that won't be connected however
since that statement even Phoenix
himself has come out and said that he
would be interested in returning for the
role the movie grossed a billion dollars
Phoenix is already winning Best Actor
Awards laughs right and center so yeah
it does make sense for Warner Brothers
to get the creative team back at any
cost I personally believe that they will
be doing whatever they can behind the
scenes to at least leave some ties here
so that maybe one day possibly in a
sequel we could see the two go
head-to-head
if the Batman does well then this could
be a massive massive film and obviously
fanhype will be there to make sure it's
worth it oh yeah just just imagine
seeing Phoenix's Joker go up against a
Batman you can't tell me you don't want
to see it now what this time setting
does is that it also leaves the door
open for tying this version of Batman in
with the larger DC EU though Batman V
Superman and Justice League
underperformed characters like Aquaman
Wonder Woman and Shazam have gone on to
have great success birds of prey is
still going ahead and so on so it is
possible at DC could want to tie
everything together so they have a
streamlined universe with the recasts we
do know that Batman and BBS has been
operating for roughly about 20 years and
with this movie being set in the 2000s
there is potential that this younger
version of the character could tie into
the one that we see later I think the
whole 2000s thing has been put in place
just to leave the door open just in case
they want to tie them together and yet
there's a lot of food for thought there
and I do think these time settings leave
a lot of wiggle room for the studio to
begin to bring everything together who
knows we might end up finding out that
the Joker from Suicide Squad was a
version of Jason Todd as was theorized
but yeah
keep your eyes peeled now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on these
photos and if you agree with my theory
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the news that the defenders
are now going to be used in Marvel
properties we go over the entire store
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me into our
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's pretty adjoining we
have an awesome community so hopefully
you see over there very soon well also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the
last year and all you have to do to be
in with a chance of winning is like the
video make she subscribed and leave your
thoughts on the photos in the comment
section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprise so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best not see you next
time take care peace
when day comes into space